ايران وروسيا والصينيه ابرز ثلاثه
التهديدات امنيه خارجيه تواجهها بريطانيا
التهديدات حددها كان مكلم رئيس جهاز
استخباراتها الداخليه بثلاث مناطق جغرافيه
اذا حذر من ان ايران تخطط لاستهداف من
تعتبرهم اعداء نظامها على الاراضي
البريطانيه هذا التحذير جاء بعد اسبوع من
استدعاء الخارجيه البريطانيه للقائم
باعمال السفاره الايرانيه للتاكيد على ان
بريطانيا لن تتسامح بتهديد او ترهيب حياه
اي شخص على اراضيها ايران
العدوانيه وهذا التهديد يشمل في اقصى
درجاته
او مقيمين ينظر اليهم على انهم اعداء
النظام
في خطابه السنوي عن التهديدات قال مكلم ان
بريطانيا ستضطر الى مواجهه العدوان
الروسيه المتزايد لسنوات قادمه مضيفا ان
روسيا تنفذ هجمات الكترونيه وعمليه تظليل
وتجسس وتتدخل في العمليه الديمقراطيه في
بريطانيا
رفضنا لاسباب تتعلق بالامن القومي اكثر من
100 طلب تاشيره دبلوماسيه روسيه ونعمل
لجعل المملكه المتحده اصعب بيئه عمل ممكنه
للانشطه السريه الروسيه
اما الصين فتوصل سعيها للتاثير على
سياسيين واشخاص في وقت مبكر من حياتهم
وبحسب مكلم فهي تستخدم كل الوسائل المتاحه
لمراقبه والترهيب الشتات الصيني ولاعاده
بعض مواطنها قصرا في ما محليا لا يزال
الارهاب المستوحى من الاديولوجيه
الاسلاميه المتطرفه يمثل حوالي ثلاثه
ارباع قضايا الارهاب مع تسجيل في محاولات
اليمين المتطرف للحصول على الاسلحه
الناريه وتاجيج المظالم وتضخيم نظريه
المؤامره
عن هذه التهديدات ياتي في سياق التقييمه
للاوضاع الامنيه والمخاطر الداخليه
والخارجيه وهي محاوله لطمئنه الراي العام
هنا ان الاجهزه الامنيه مدركه للتحديات
التي تواجهها بريطانيا لكنها محاوله قد
تكون صعبه وسط تزايد المخاطر النجمه عن
التطورات السياسيه مصطفى زاروه العربيه
لندن